My name's Kelly.
I am from OurDeerlyDeparted,
and I am a taxidermist.
And today, I'm going to show you guys
how I restore a taxidermy dog.
Apparently, Cutty was a very
famous dog in West Virginia.
She was a dog that lived in a gas station,
so everyone knew her.
She sat in a window for a very long time.
She was sun bleached, so
she lost all of her color.
Her ears were broken,
and she was missing an eye.
So, the first step is to basically
go over the animal, see
what's wrong with it,
and I always check and see if there's any
remnants of bugs or a
possible infestation.
So, I'm blowing it with a vacuum.
If I don't blow off that dust,
the dirt is going to be
pushed down into the fur
after I wipe it.
Cutty was very fragile.
Fur was coming out.
Her ears were basically falling off.
So certain parts like that,
you have to be super
careful when cleaning it.
I just use rubbing alcohol.
I don't want to use too much of it,
because it can dry out the animal,
but it's a really good
cleaner for taxidermy.
The black stuff coming
off of her head is paint.
And I just had to work at it,
be super delicate with it,
because that wire brush
can tear out the hair
if you're not careful.
So I was going in circular motions
and kind of just working the paint off
and taking a paper towel, wiping it off,
and just being super slow with it
and really taking my time.
Her ears were both cracked.
This is a really common thing
that can happen with ears.
Her ears had to be restrengthened.
So, what I first did was I actually
rehydrated them with water.
I stuffed the ears with some cotton balls,
paper towels,
just something that
would hold the moisture,
and wrapped them in Saran wrap.
It's just to kind of keep
everything nice and moist
so I could work on it.
I let them sit for about a day.
Sometimes with old taxidermy,
if you rehydrate it too much,
it could actually fall apart,
so you really have to watch that.
After the ears were rehydrated,
I filled it first with clay,
and I also filled the ears with Bondo.
That really strengthened
her ears up a lot.
And then after her ears were strengthened,
I went over top of the Bondo
with some Apoxie Sculpt,
just to kind of even it out
and fill in those cracks.
Her one eye was really
great, looked awesome,
but her other eye was missing.
When I did start to clean
out what was left of it,
there was actually some glass.
So what I had to do was actually
remove the other eye that looked OK,
because I wasn't able to
match the eyes exactly.
I couldn't find anything to replicate it.
So I didn't want to go in
and put in a different eye
that was a shade lighter.
Again, I rehydrated it,
removed the other eye,
and replaced them with
brand-new glass eyes.
I actually added some
more clay into the eye
to give it that extra detail
and to make the eye sit
in there really nicely.
They were actually bear eyes, I believe,
because they don't make dog eyes.
It was about the same
size and color as a dog.
When replacing eyes,
it definitely is tricky,
because it's backwards
of how you would typically do taxidermy.
So, when you're mounting something fresh,
those eyes go on before the skin goes on.
So I'm doing it completely backwards
and adding the clay in
after the eyes are in there.
She was missing, I want to say,
two or three of her original nails.
Coyote nails were about the closest thing
I could find to dog nails.
And I just happened to have
a few of them laying around,
and they worked perfectly.
After all of her parts are repaired,
it's time to airbrush Cutty
back to her original color.
I choose to airbrush taxidermy
just because it creates a really nice,
natural look to them.
You can really control
how much paint is applied,
and you're able to paint really big areas
with a lot of paint very quickly.
The paints I used are
actually lacquer paints.
They're called LifeTone paints,
and they are made for taxidermy animals.
They're special colors that
are made for painting skin
and replicating those color tones
that are found in animals.
With Cutty, I was layering
those colors a lot on there.
I started out with a really light yellow
and some of the darker colors on her face,
and I'd go over with a more orangey color
to make that yellow pop out
from underneath her fur.
What I did for Cutty's muzzle,
she was missing fur.
One way to replace fur is to add flocking.
I went in with a black and brown flocking,
and I mixed it together.
I applied it with Mod Podge.
So just typical craft glue.
Flocking is basically a
crushed velvet material,
and you're able to
spray that onto the skin
and recreate a really short fur texture.
And then I painted over
top of that for, again,
to really tie it all together
and make the colors look seamless,
make these pieces last a life.
The tongue was yellow
from it being in the sun.
I just painted it with acrylic
paints to restore that color.
Taxidermy pieces usually never need
to really be maintained or restored
if they're kept in the right conditions.
I've seen pieces that
are hundreds of years old
and are in almost perfect condition.
Generally, just dusting pieces,
keeping them out of the
sunlight, maintaining,
and making sure that
there's no infestations
make these pieces last a lifetime.